[Music]
what are those things a member of the
exploration team asks pointing to
hundreds of clear orbs he begins moving
towards the mysterious objects progress
is slow the bulky spacesuit is meant to
withstand the planet's hostile
conditions but doesn't allow for much
maneuverability they look like canisters
containing some sort of creature the scp
agent says dr sanders points his
headlamp in the direction of the voice
mother of god he whispers into his
helmet stop moving he yells are those
eggs nothing is supposed to be able to
survive on this planet that's why it was
chosen for off-world testing and
containment for the foundation's
deadliest entities the team points their
lights at the orbs the creatures inside
don't seem to be moving they are
suspended in some type of gel and when
the light hits them the creatures look
like metallic squids dr sanders holds up
his hand to signal the rest of the team
to stop moving i thought i saw some
activity he says the team looks around
but they don't see anything i must be
jumping at shadows grab the equipment
let's get out of here we need to contact
scp command and find out what they want
us to do with these things the team
packs up their gear and makes their way
out of the cave system beneath the alien
planet's surface as they exit the mouth
of the cave they are greeted by a
nighttime sky filled with stars and
nebula the undesignated planet is
located in the deep recesses of space
the only light on this part of the
planet comes from the suits of dr
sanders's team without any light
pollution like on earth it seems as if
every part of the universe is visible if
it wasn't so creepy here it'd be kind of
beautiful one of the team members says
all of the scp agents have stopped
walking and stare up at the cosmos come
on says dr sanders let's get back to
elena and find out what the o5 council
wants us to do with this new discovery
the next night the exploration team is
back at the caverns where they
discovered the mysterious orbs the
previous evening dr sanders leads his
team into the winding tunnel system it
leads directly under one of the largest
mountain ranges on the planet they
approach the chamber that contains the
clear orbs and get to work collecting
samples to bring back to the lab we have
no idea what these things actually are
so be careful if you see movement
immediately back away i want teams of
two for each pod one person collects a
sample the other holds the incinerator
at the ready just in case you need to
fry whatever is inside these things the
team members confirm their orders and
get to work everything goes according to
plan the samples are gathered and the
scp team makes its way out of the
caverns when they get to the surface dr
sanders radios to the command center at
elena we're out from under the mountain
canisters have been secured estimated
time to the rover is four minutes we'll
update when end route to base roger that
extraction team will have the loading
bay ready for your arrival response the
communications officer at elena sanders
and his crew board the rover and put the
canisters in the storage compartment the
drive back to elena is uneventful the
entire planet is basically made up of
dust and rocks until yesterday everyone
at elena thought they were the only
living things out here other than the
few dangerous scps they brought along
with them to experiment on the rover
pulls into the research base and parks
outside the airlock the team carries the
canisters into the storage dome for
further analysis before heading to
decontamination sanders walks out of the
airlock and takes off his helmet brain
we brought back the orbs and they're
awaiting your analysis in the storage
bay i don't know what they are but the
fact that they might be alive will be of
great interest to the foundation i look
forward to examining the specimens we're
kind of backed up right now but we'll
get around to it you know saving the
best for last and all researcher brain
responds there's a delicate matter that
we're attending to at the moment it
should be resolved soon breen looks down
at the clipboard he's holding in front
i've got to go but i'll keep you updated
after a few days brian calls dr sanders
into his lab you're going to want to see
this it's those weird egg type specimens
you brought back from the caverns
they've been designated as cp 1124
perfect i've been dying to know what
these things are sanders says as he
enters the lab do you mind if i record
this just so i have something to send
back to my superiors at the foundation
breen agrees and the two scp researchers
begin their analysis of the clear orbs
so they're not made of glass like we
originally thought breen begins we
actually aren't entirely sure what these
things are made of they definitely have
the shape of an egg but the solid clear
outer layer makes me think they are more
like carrying containers than anything
else see look bree grabs the top of one
of the orbs and pulls it off there is a
satisfying pump like a champagne cork
exploding out of the top of a bottle dr
sanders looks at the lid and then
watches as breen puts the top back on
the orb but that's not the weirdest part
breen says take a look at what's inside
sanders leans over the opened orb and
looks into it the creature inside looks
like a silver squid it does not move but
sanders gets an uneasy feeling as if
there is something inherently dangerous
and evil about the metallic squids come
over here i have some laid out on the
table for you to examine says breen they
walk over to another lab bench where
there are several creatures laid out
breen uses forceps to move the appendage
of one of the creatures the limbs are
segmented but there is no sign of eyes
or mouth as far as sanders can tell what
are they asks sanders no idea but watch
this breen picks up one of the creatures
with the forceps by the tentacle sanders
expects the arm to be flexible and
rubbery like a squids but instead they
are stiff and rigid like a knife when
breen picks up the limb the entire
creature moves with it like a statue he
pulls out a scalpel and looks at dr
sanders watch this he says nothing
happens as breen presses the blade
against scp-1124's exoskeleton he pushes
harder and harder and harder eventually
the scalpel breaks and the blade clangs
to the floor we haven't been able to
break the shell so we don't know exactly
what's inside but i have a few ideas on
how to crack this puppy open brain says
with a smile he pulls out a blowtorch
and begins blasting the metallic squid
with the flame there is no effect breen
then brings out a vat of liquid nitrogen
he picks up one of the creatures and
places it inside the canister when he
pulls it out the instance of scp-1124 is
covered in frost breen grabs a hammer
off of one of the lab tables and smashes
it down onto the shell there's a clank
as if the hammer struck a metal pole
brain shakes his hand which is now
throbbing from the reverberations sent
through the hammer on impact
maybe they aren't alive after all
chuckles dr sanders maybe they're just
figurines or statues or something that's
what i was starting to think too replies
brain ugh what a waste of time sanders
says he hawks a loogie and spits at
scp-1124 in disgust the spit hits the
outer shell and slowly begins to run
down the side dr sanders and breen take
a seat at one of the tables it seemed
like those things were going to hold
some real promise maybe even get us off
this rock yes the orbs and whatever is
inside of them are real duds breen
commiserates guess it's time to focus on
suddenly one of the arms of the
creatures that dr sanders spat on begins
to move did you see that bring yells
this the squid thing it just moved its
arm breen and sanders run to the lab
table where the instance of scp-1124
slowly stretches its tentacles as if
feeling its surroundings to get a better
idea of its location breen reaches out
to touch one of the metallic arms stop
don't touch it dr sanders yells but it's
too late the creature makes contact with
breen's skin it instantly comes alive
all of its tentacles are now moving
freely the ends have sharpened tips the
creature jerks one of its tentacles
slashing breen's neck blood spatters
across the room covering several other
instances of scp-1124
as the blood touches them they slowly
come to life their tentacles move all
around as if searching for the source of
the bodily fluid dr sanders shrieks for
help he sprints towards the door but
before he can reach it one of the
instances of scp-1124 launches itself
off of a table and impales its spiked
arms into sander's back he screams in
pain tears fall down the sides of his
cheek as his hand slams against the
glass door that leads out of the lab the
creature climbs up his back and over his
head he then pries dr sanders mouth open
and squirms down his throat as he is
torn apart from the inside by the metal
tentacles of scp-1124
his hand slides down the door leaving a
bloody handprint the audio recorder
continues to run in the lab it picks up
the unsettling sounds of metal on metal
and the guttural screeches of the
scp-1124 creatures the glass door
leading from the lab to the rest of the
elena facility shatters instances of
scp-1124 comes streaming out the
researchers at the base have no idea
that one of the most dangerous scps the
foundation has ever faced is now
squirming along the halls of the
facility looking for hosts to lay their
eggs inside years go by without any
communication from elena the foundation
assumes something has gone wrong but
that was the point of setting up the
base on a faraway planet in the first
place if an experiment got out of hand
or a dangerous scp escaped the only
people who would be in danger were the
agents and class d personnel at elena it
was a much safer alternative to
conducting these sorts of experiments on
earth the o5 council redacts much of the
information on elena and the research
happening there the file is buried deep
within the foundation's database and
forgotten that is until several years
later when a ship from elena crashed
lands just outside an air force base in
nevada general we've just received word
from the foundation that one of our deep
space research vessels has crashed in
the desert not too far from here the o5
council has asked that we sent a team to
recover whatever's on board apparently
it came from a base called elena never
heard of it responds to the general all
right let's send a task force to go
retrieve whatever's on board that thing
a group of scp scientists and agents are
dispatched to carry out reconnaissance
and containment procedures for the
crashed elena rocket there is very
little information on what to expect as
most of the reports and documents about
elena are classified as the team sets
out to recover whatever is on board the
rocket a reptile-like creature that has
remained dormant at the base for the
last 30 years twitches no one notices
the slight movement even though this scp
is heavily guarded and deemed one of the
biggest threats to humanity's very
existence general we've reached the
crash site one of the agents radios back
to the air base the rocket is in rough
shape but the cargo hold seems to be
intact we're opening it now the
extraction team uses welding torches to
cut through the outer lock of the
capsule they pull back the door and peer
inside what are those things one of the
agents asks as the flashlight moves
across the cargo hold the team can see
hundreds of glassy orbs packed tightly
into the space within the rocket well
let's get them back to the base so they
can be analyzed says the team leader
using recommended containment procedures
the extraction team carefully removes
each of the orbs and loads them onto a
transport helicopter all of the agents
wear protective hazmat suits and no one
is allowed to directly come into contact
with the orbs once the helicopter is
loaded it takes off and returns to the
air force base the chopper lands and a
team of researchers load the orb into a
containment pod which is then
immediately brought to the lab for
analysis i finally found some
information on what elena was and what
these things might be the lead scientist
at the base informs the other
researchers it took a lot of digging but
i'm pretty sure the orbs are classified
as
scp-1124 as far as i can tell they
contain some kind of squid-like statue
but the information from elena is kind
of spotty not exactly sure what happened
up there the other researchers listen as
they're briefed we're pretty much
starting from scratch here so be careful
and use proper containment procedures as
if you're dealing with an unknown scp
the lead scientist finishes the
researchers nod to indicate they've
heard what their bosses had to say and
then get to work deep underground the
reptilian creature still lies dormant
there are slight fluctuations in the
thermal readings in its containment
chamber but the beast does not seem to
wake the scp agents on duty note in
their log that the thermal sensors might
need to be recalibrated the researchers
enter a clean room and lock themselves
inside they have brought in one of the
scp-1124 orbs for further analysis as
the researcher who is holding the orb
walks towards the table in the middle of
the room he accidentally trips the other
researcher reaches out and tries to grab
his colleague but misses the orb falls
to the ground the researcher scrapes his
leg on the corner of the table he
doesn't notice the tear in his
protective suit where a small trickle of
blood drips onto the floor ah that
really hurt the researcher says rubbing
his shin the orb rolls in a circle on
the ground it slowly comes to a stop
right on top of a drop of blood from the
injured researcher the orb begins to
shudder both of the scientists look in
shock as it rolls along the floor
banging into the containment chamber
walls as if it was looking for a way out
the researchers jump to their feet and
run after the oar one of the scientists
grab the orb off the ground and holds it
tightly in both hands suddenly a hole
appears in the orb surface the
researcher looks at one another their
eyes wide in terror the researcher
holding the orb puts his hand over the
hole to cover it he instantly recoils in
pain as something stabs him from within
a metallic tentacle appears through the
hole in the orb followed by a creature
with a squid-like body the creature
remains motionless sensing the room
around him the scientist not holding the
orb races towards the storage closet to
find something to cover the hole with
the other researcher remains motionless
hoping that the creature will just go
back into its container without warning
the creature launches itself at the
faceplate of the researcher holding the
oar it smashes through the protective
shielding and enters the mouth of the
researcher the other scientist screams
in terror he runs out of the containment
chamber and slams down the button to
activate the failsafe to prevent a
containment breach the room begins to
fill with mist and triflic acid alarms
sound in the lab other scp personnel
come rushing in they watch in horror as
the head of the researcher with scp-1124
inside of him starts to expand blood
begins to pour out of his nose eyes and
ears then with a gruesome pop the
researcher's head explodes the
researchers leaned closer to the window
to get a better look at what's happening
they scan the room when suddenly an
instance of scp-1124 slams into the
observation glass the researchers jump
back in surprise a crack runs the length
of the observation window at the same
time the alarms are going off in the
research lab different alarms sound deep
within the facility sensors have picked
up a huge jump in thermal energy in the
reptilian creature's chamber along with
the movement of its tail and limbs armed
scp foundation agents run towards the
containment chamber but when they are
only a few feet away the blast door is
forced off its hinges and slams against
the far wall of the complex the
containment team screeches to a halt as
scp-682 slowly lumbers out of its cell
and shakes its body the creature locks
eyes with the agents who are frozen in
shock it curls back its lips to reveal
razor sharp teeth saliva falls to the
floor open fire one of the agents yells
they fire a barrage of bullets at
scp-682
but they seem to have no effect the
creature stalks towards the agents and
uses its claws and teeth to tear them
apart
scp-682 runs through the facility
killing every living thing in its path
it bursts out into the sunlight where it
sniffs the air it then sprints towards
the high density fence and bursts
through it as if it was nothing more
than cobwebs
scp-682 runs in the direction of the
crashed elena rocket a battalion of
agents is deployed to stop scp-682
but the monster quickly destroys anyone
and anything in its path it seems to be
on a mission and nothing will stop it
when scp-682 reaches the rocket it
consumes the entire research team that
is there examining the spacecraft it
then begins sniffing around the area and
climbs into the cargo hold it's looking
for something mobile task force iota 5
approaches the rocket in two teams the
first is on the ground in armored
vehicles the second is in a helicopter
they have a plan it seems that scp-682
is looking for the orbs that were inside
the rocket for some reason they are
incredibly important to scp-682
and it will stop at nothing to find them
scp-682 is acting like a mother
searching for a lost child mobile task
force iota 5 has brought one of the
scp-1120 orbs with them in hopes they
can lure scp-682 back to its containment
chamber when the first team approaches
in the chopper
scp-682 stops its search the creature
sniffs the air and spots the helicopter
oh i think he spotted us says the pilot
the ground force opens fire on scp-682
the creature does not seem interested in
them instead
scp-682 remains fixated on the
helicopter as if it knows there is an
orb on board the creature leaps off the
rocket and begins running towards the
helicopter the pilot turns the chopper
and flies away with scp-682 in pursuit
they make it back to the air force base
just ahead of scp-682
one of the agents jumps out of the
helicopter with the scp-1124
orb in his hands he races towards a
mobile containment chamber where he
places the orb at the far end before
turning to get out when he looks up
scp-682 is standing in the doorway its
chest heaves up and down its eyes are
wild the scp agent raises his gun and
fires
scp-682 snarls and leads into the
containment chamber the whole thing
shakes as the agent is torn apart his
gunshots and screams are silenced as the
door to the containment chamber shuts
the fiasco known as the grey dragon
incident is an embarrassment to the
foundation the o5 council has everyone
involved terminated
scp-682 is secured in a new containment
facility far away from
scp-1124 and the mysterious orbs are
placed in their own containment chamber
and hidden away from the world the
working hypothesis is that
scp-1124 are the eggs of scp-682
but further tests will need to be done
and since both of these scps are
extremely dangerous these experiments
might need to be conducted on a far away
planet perhaps it is time for the scp
foundation to revisit elena once again
let's just hope this time they don't
bring anything else back now watch
scp-682 waze scp foundation try to kill
hard to destroy reptile or check out how
to kill scp-682 theories and ideas for
more on the monster we all know and fear